ever notice how heroes just emerge
they're not so much
born as they just appear out of nowhere
and that happened a few years ago in
this country now that hero went by many
names
we called him the creepy porn lawyer
because he was but over at cnn they
called him something different
they called him a future president i
value most if they decide they value a
fighter most
yes people would be foolish to
underestimate michael avenatti an
existential threat to the trump
presidency
please welcome attorney michael avenatti
no one has talked tougher directly to
donald trump on tv than michael avenatti
and donald trump is afraid to mention
his name michael avenatti is a beast
okay that's true
and he's a beast he's a beast and he
keeps popping donald trump and all of
his folks in the mouth
repeatedly he's a beast and so uh john
meacham says he may be the savior of the
republic
i owe michael avenatti an apology for
the last couple of weeks i've been
saying enough for reading michael i've
seen you everywhere what do you have
left to say
i was wrong brother those were not cable
news clips that was an iq test and
everybody on that tape failed miserably
do not issue them driver's licenses
they're not capable
they fell for it hard in a single week
in march of 2018 if you can remember
that far back msnbc cnn abc cbs and nbc
news
interviewed the creepy porn lawyer a
total of not making this up
because we counted 147 times
we got to get in on that we got to
interview the creepy porn lawyer
we had only one opportunity to talk to
him in studio
here's part of it you've profited from
stormy daniels
you've done tens of millions of dollars
worth of free media on the basis of your
relationship with her
and she's working in strip clubs you're
exploiting her
and you know that why aren't you paying
her some of what you're making sir this
is absurd
but answer my question why are you rich
and your client is working in cd strip
clubs sir do you have any idea how much
money i've earned
you're on every cable show you're
running for president now i have no idea
i know that you haven't paid your taxes
and like so many lawyers you were taking
advantage of her
and you pose as a feminist hero because
you are shameless and the other channels
let you get away with it but you're an
exploiter of a woman and you should be
ashamed of it
so it wasn't the warmest interview ever
and actually got even
more unpleasant off air but we wanted to
give you the coda to the story how did
it wind up where is he now well today
the creepy porn lawyer
met the fate so many of us knew was
coming to him he was sentenced to 30
months in prison
in this case we're trying to extort the
shoe company nike
although he's still facing several
separate trials including one concerning
allegations he defrauded stormy daniels
which he apparently did
so the question for us is basically a
political show is what does this mean
for creepy porn lawyers presidential
ambitions
is he still what american needs francie
hanks is a former federal prosecutor she
joins us tonight francie thanks so much
for coming on and i should say
in with some sincerity i never gloat
over a man going to prison because i you
know it's sad it's like someone's death
it is said i mean that
however if there was ever a guy who had
a rendezvous with a cell
inevitably it was this guy was that
obvious to you as a former prosecutor
yeah you know tucker he certainly had
that uh defense attorney bluster that
incredible arrogance that used to drive
me so crazy across the courtroom
when they were performing really for an
audience of one their own client
and never for the jury and never for the
judge he was really
just like a normal criminal defense
attorney to me but
today in court he certainly didn't have
that arrogance as he was apparently
sobbing with regret and i just have to
say that's one of the things that used
to drive me the most crazy
as a prosecutor was watching the
defendant next to me
cry and sob because where was that
emotion
where was that regret when they were
victimizing their victims and here
you had he had an extortion scheme
it's not like i feel sorry for the shoe
company but the point
is that he's got an extortion scheme to
extort a shoe company he's paying the
price now he's going to prison
for less than the federal sentencing
guidelines recommended by the way which
was nine years
but still i'm not at all surprised that
he had
such a rise and such a meteoric fall
also
what about the dignity question i mean
there are all kinds of figures
throughout history who mount the gallows
to their death without crying aren't you
supposed to kind of man up and
keep your little tears inside i mean i'm
i'm sincere like whatever happened to
that standard
well where was the beast they were all
talking about how he was such a beast
and how president
trump was afraid of him and he goes into
court and just like almost
every other criminal cries when he has
to face the music
for what he's done yeah there is a
connection between
narcissism and self-pity have you
noticed that definitely
francie hinks not just a former
prosecutor but a student of human
behavior
thank you great to see you thanks tucker
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else